y
rusia despidió a mijail gorbachov en
moscú el último líder de la unión
soviética murió el pasado martes a los
91 años y fue enterrado este sábado sin
honras de estado ni la presencia del
presidente vladimir putin su cuerpo fue
velado en el icónico salón de las
columnas de moscú
la unión europea' se declara preparada
para afrontar el desabastecimiento de
gas ruso así lo anunció el comisario
europeo de economía paolo gentiloni
después de que la empresa estatal rusa
gazprom
informará del corte total e indefinido
del suministro a través del gasoducto
nord stream 1
cancelado por segunda vez el lanzamiento
de artemis uno de la nasa la agencia
espacial estadounidense argumentó una
nueva fuga de hidrógeno en el cohete
como motivo de la suspensión de la
misión que pretende que la humanidad
regrese a la luna tenemos reporte desde
florida
buenas tardes bienvenidos a las noticias
de france 24
soy rosa pérez más de ohl y es para mí
un gusto acompañarles empezamos en rusia
porque mijail gorbachov el último líder
de la unión soviética fallecido el
martes fue despedido por familiares y
ciudadanos en el mismo cementerio donde
reposa el cuerpo de su esposa en moscú
aunque el kremlin no le otorgó el honor
de dedicarle un funeral de estado y el
propio presidente vladimir putin no
acudió al entierro
el gobierno ruso sí que le concedió el
reconocimiento de ser velado en el
mítico salón de las columnas velatorio
de otros líderes soviéticos el informe
es de alva santana
último adiós de rusia mijaíl gorbachov
rodeado de sus seres queridos y de miles
de seguidores el último líder de la
antigua unión soviética fue enterrado en
moscú tras morir a los 91 años
creo que esta persona se merecía una
ceremonia de despedida verdaderamente
popular es una persona histórica
independientemente de lo que piense en
algunos hizo mucho aunque algunos
piensan que hizo más mal que bien yo
creo que hizo más bien
y es que el político reformista lideró
al final de la guerra fría y marcó la
apertura de rusia al mundo en los 90 en
lo que finalmente acabó con la unión
soviética fue enterrado sin la
característica ceremonia de estado de
sus predecesores y sin retransmisión en
directo de la televisión estatal además
de contar con una gran ausencia la del
presidente vladimir putin que se limitó
a llevarle un ramo de rosas tras
conocerse su muerte el martes
debemos apreciar las cosas buenas que
gorbachov hizo por nosotros contribuyó
mucho al desarrollo de los medios de
comunicación de la sociedad civil y en
general apoyo a nuestro país en el
ámbito internacional
con claveles y rosas rojas cientos de
rusos hicieron fila frente a la famosa
casa de los sindicatos de moscú donde se
celebró la ceremonia de despedida de
gorbachov quien con su huida remarca el
fin de una era en rusia ahora en medio
de una nueva guerra
y la central nuclear de zamorilla fue
desconectada de nuevo de la red
eléctrica ucraniana pero continúa
suministrando energía a través de una
línea de reserva así informaron el
organismo internacional de la energía
atómica porque recordamos que dos
expertos del organismo
continúan en la planta en el marco de
una misión de control para evitar un
desastre nuclear fruto de los combates
en la zona de hecho el ministerio de
defensa de rusia anunció este sábado que
frenó un ataque ucraniano que intentaba
retomar el control de la planta según el
ejército ruso tropas ucranianas llegaron
en helicópteros y buques a un lago
centro cercano a la central las fuerzas
rusas aseguran haber matado a 47
militares de que los moderada presos a
pesar de la presencia de representantes
de loja en la central nuclear de savory
ya el régimen de kiev intentó una vez
más apoderarse de la central el 2 de
septiembre alrededor de las 23 horas de
moscú los grupos de un total de 42
embarcaciones con más de 2 150 militares
de las fuerzas de operaciones especiales
y mercenarios extranjeros a bordo
intentaron desembarcar en la orilla del
embalse de kafka cerca de enero dar
rayones en la caldera línea producto
la empresa alemana siemens desmintió el
discurso de la empresa estatal rusa
gazprom sobre la suspensión del flujo de
gas a europa a través del gaseoducto nos
tribuno gazprom asegura que una fuga de
aceite detectada en una turbina durante
las tareas de mantenimiento impide la
entrega de gas sin embargo siemens
asegura que incidencias de este tipo en
el pasado no conllevaron el cese de la
actividad por otro lado recordemos que
la presidente de la comisión europea
úrsula von der leyen declaró esta semana
la intención de bruselas de intervenir
el mercado energético europeo y este
sábado el comisario europeo de economía
paolo gentiloni aseguró que la unión
europea está preparada para la
interrupción del gas ruso
putin para un paso útil dando un paso
más hacia el corte de los suministros
una violación de contrato sería una
violación de los contratos todos esperan
que eso no suceda si sucede es claro que
habrá consecuencias pero también es
claro que nos hemos estado preparando
durante meses para este riesgo por lo
que no debemos subestimar los bloques
tories que prendieron tope a moso pero
ciertamente no nos dejaremos intimidar
de manera que farc sin timidez y
seguimos con información relativa a las
tensiones entre china y taiwán
beijing exigió a eeuu la suspensión del
acuerdo con taiwán bajo pena de
represalias el acuerdo entre taipei y
washington prevé una posible compra de
material militar por valor de 1.100
millones de dólares
se trataría del mayor contrato
armamentístico en la historia de ambos
gobiernos el departamento de estado de
eeuu aprobó la venta como represalia a
las maniobras militares chinas en el
estrecho de taiwán unas maniobras que
recordemos fueron desencadenadas por la
visita a taiwán de nancy pelosi quienes
presiden de la cámara de representantes
de eeuu
previamente conversamos con fernando
pedrosa profesor de ciencia política de
la universidad de buenos aires él nos
explicó el estado de las tensiones entre
eeuu y china acerca de la cuestión de
taiwán
bueno lo primero que podemos decir es
que esto muestra que la visita de nancy
pelosi no era sólo un capricho de ella
sino que tenía que ver con una política
de aquel momento el presidente valle
intentó despegarse pero estaba yo creo
que consensuado con la representante de
legislativa ahora la denuncia de
casablanca pero todavía faltaría que el
congreso norteamericano lo vote no es
menor eso es una partida de 1100
visuales como usted dijeron para comprar
radares y misiles ni una invasión
inmediata ni un conflicto armado
inmediato sigue que menciona también que
china tiene algunos problemas por los
cuales tiene que mostrarse activa y
sólida e internacionalmente a problemas
económicos están mal con la crisis
económica y hay cifras de crecimiento
mil novecientas peladas el prueba del
cómic cero acaban de encerrar una ciudad
con 21 millones de habitantes siendo un
futuro congreso de partido comunista con
bastantes discusiones internas y con
impugnaciones también para el presidente
sí y por último la guerra de ucrania que
lo sigue le sigues creando problemas a
nivel internacional o sea que también
está usando esto como una manera digamos
de distraer algunas otras discusiones de
su población
y en pakistán las inundaciones afectan a
un tercio del territorio y a 33 millones
de personas lo que representa el 15 por
ciento de la población del país en su
último informe las autoridades de
islamabad reportaron 57 muertes más lo
que aumenta el total de fallecidos a
1.265 desde que comenzaron las lluvias
monzónicas a mediados de junio los
detalles con de aurel
como este pueblo muchos se convirtieron
en ríos en pakistán las inundaciones sin
presentes siguen forzando a miles de
personas a huir de sus casas y
enfrentarse a instalaciones deplorables
en condiciones de hacinamiento hacia el
área nos salvamos de morir ahogados en
las inundaciones pero nuestra casa se
derrumbó escapamos pero no pudimos
salvar nuestros bienes bell con la alga
tengamos aquí en un estado terrible
algunas buenas personas de aquí nos
dieron refugio ahora estamos recibiendo
algo de ayuda del gobierno pero sólo
suficiente para llenar nuestros
estómagos roger ahora es la organización
de naciones unidas alerta que estas
condiciones precarias ponen
especialmente en riesgo la vida de los
niños por la propagación de enfermedades
transmitidas a través del agua de las
1200 personas que fallecieron más de 400
eran menores el sábado el gobierno
paquistaní advirtió nuevamente la
urgencia de la situación que los que el
off de base station es va a ser la
escala de la devastación es masiva y
requiere una inmensa respuesta
humanitaria para 33 millones de personas
rimmel y en vivo por ello hago un
llamamiento a mis compatriotas a los
paquistaníes expatriados y a la
comunidad internacional para que ayuden
a pakistán en esta hora de necesidad
funcionarios y expertos achacan el nivel
inusual de lluvias monzónicas en
pakistán al cambio climático entre ellos
el secretario general de la onu antonio
guterres que instó al mundo a dejar de
caminar durmiendo en esta crisis
guterres recorrerán las zonas afectadas
por las inundaciones en pakistán el
próximo 9 de septiembre
y vamos a costa rica donde las
solicitudes de asilo sobrepasan la
capacidad de la oficina que las tramita
gran parte de las peticiones de refugio
provienen de emigrantes de la vecina
nicaragua que huyen en busca de un
futuro mejor un fenómeno que supera las
cifras de los años 80 cuando las guerras
civiles obligaron a cientos de personas
a huir de sus hogares andrés granadillo
tiene los detalles de un sistema
colapsado debido a la cantidad de
solicitudes de asilo de nicaragüenses en
costa rica por lo que la agencia de la
onu para los refugiados ayuda con
personal el sistema de refugio de costa
rica ha tenido dificultades para hacer
frente a ese incremento tan importante
de solicitudes de refugio que ha habido
desde 2018 el acnur ha apoyado al
gobierno de costa rica mediante la
contratación de 50 personas en la unidad
de refugio que ayudan a procesar estos
casos y hacer frente al rezago ahora de
tantos años este por la acumulación de
casos las peticiones suman unas 200.000
una cifra que representa el 4 por ciento
de la población costarricense y son más
de los que hubo en la década de los 80
durante el éxodo ocasionado por las
guerras civiles en la región unas 50.000
personas están esperando cita para hacer
una solicitud formal costa rica con 5
millones de habitantes fue el segundo
país después de eeuu en recibir el mayor
número de aplicaciones de asilo la cifra
se ha incrementado desde 2021 cuando el
presidente nicaragüense daniel ortega
arremetió contra la oposición y
encarceló parte de ella costa rica sigue
siendo la primera opción para los
nicaragüenses que emigran un mayor
motivo de juego por beneficio de trabajo
trabajito que uno puede lograr a tener
allá
es complicado para mantenimiento de la
familia
y gracias a dios aquí en costa rica nos
dan el apoyo de
trabajar y ayudar un poco más a la
familia
muchos de ellos al ver la demora en sus
peticiones ponen sus ojos hacia eeuu y
méxico donde esperan lejos de casa tener
un futuro
y vamos a florida porque hace unas horas
conocíamos la noticia de que la nasa
suspendió por segunda vez el lanzamiento
de la misión artemis 1 por una fuga en
el conducto del combustible del cohete
se retrasa de nuevo el paso previo al
regreso de la humanidad a la luna luego
de 50 años y el despegue queda ahora
fijado para el próximo lunes desde la
base espacial kennedy en nuestro enviado
especial
anthony belchí nos habló del comunicado
de la nasa y nos contó cómo se vivió la
noticia allí en cabo cañaveral
el lanzamiento de la misión artemisa ha
sido cancelada por segunda vez en los
ingenieros de la administración nacional
de aeronáutica y el espacio de eeuu la
nasa a pesar de haber estado trabajando
intensamente en las últimas horas no han
podido solucionar los problemas con una
fuga de hidrógeno en uno de los motores
que afectaba también a la ventilación es
el mismo problema del lunes cuando
estaba previsto su lanzamiento ya desde
la nasa habían alertado que no había
garantía al cien por cien de que se
pudiera realizar este lanzamiento del
cohete durante este sábado porque lo
querían tener todo controlado este es un
vuelo de pruebas y sin tripulación lo
que significa que ahora es el momento de
revisar todo al milímetro y ver los
problemas que podrían surgir durante una
misión con personal a bordo ya que este
tipo de ensayos no se podrían poner en
práctica con personas en su interior ya
que podría poner en riesgo la vida de
los astronautas pese a los imprevistos
las miradas de medio mundo se han vuelto
a poner aquí en la plataforma espacial
de despegue en ciudades como estas en
titusville la más cercana a la siesta
desde la nasa más de 200.000 personas se
han congregado aprovechando que es
sábado y que muchos están disfrutando
del día del fin de semana largo por el
día del trabajo todos tenían la
esperanza de ver salir al cohete para
regresar a la luna 50 años después una
misión cuyo objetivo es el de tener una
presencia continuada en la superficie
lunar conocer el terreno para luego
enviar seres humanos a marte ese es el
objetivo final de momento hay
posibilidad de despegue el 5 o el 6 de
septiembre si no se hace entonces el
vuelo hacia la luna con artemis se
retrasaría hasta por lo menos el 19 de
septiembre
muchísimas gracias por su atención sigan
con nosotros en france24 france24
puntocom
[Música]